foreign
new details of the scene inside New
York's largest hotel that's housing
illegal migrants our next guest is
shedding light on his time at the Row
NYC Hotel reporting a 10 year old being
drunk in her hotel room without her
parents on site he's also sharing images
of trashed rooms violence in the street
and a slew of Staff incident reports
here with details Carlos Carlos Arellano
Carlos it's really great to have you on
appreciate this Insight tell us what
what you're you I know you no longer
work there but you and your former
colleagues were experiencing at this
hotel
uh just a lot of people who are very
they're they don't appreciate what they
have and they come here with the mindset
of the way they live back at their home
country
and they think there's no rules or no
laws to be followed here
did you ever feel endangered while you
were working there that things were
getting just so out of hand
every day every day and and uh former
co-workers as well
uh a lot of a lot of uh former
co-workers have reached out and are
happy that I did the interview and
they're saying this place deserves to be
shut down
that they fear for their life every
every day as as well as I did so this
hotel used to be a tourist Hotel it's
now housing illegal migrants has there
ever been a time that you or your
colleagues recall that this hotel was
used to house American homeless people
uh not not myself uh but I I did hear
well we would hear about plenty hotels
that used to house homeless people and
kick them out
yeah
so tell us about this child that you
found is that the 10 year old who was
found intoxicated is this a regular
thing that you see on you see children
by themselves without their parents in
these hotel rooms
it's an everyday thing every day we find
about
10 kids alone in their hotel rooms
either drinking or doing drugs
uh with uh weapons will be in the room
but we're not allowed to go in there
we're not allowed to take anything from
them
and it's basically a free-for-all in
this hotel yeah do you know if the
children or the parents are indeed the
parents of these children or is there
any indication about that or do you feel
like you're not sure about that
no we we know we we find fake passports
fake social security cards
uh all kinds of fake documents in this
hotel every day
by the way when you found this 10 year
old because not far away from where
we're at there was an ABC producer who
went out to dinner he died unexpectedly
on the way and his wife was arrested his
American wife was arrested because it
turned out that it through this tragedy
they found out that their children were
alone in a hotel room and she was
arrested for endangerment you know the
day after her husband died
unexpectedly has anybody been charged or
held accountable for children left alone
in hotel rooms
no they never are and if they are kicked
out of the hotel they get sent to a
processing center at Port Authority
where they get given a second Hotel so
say a husband decides to beat his wife
up he will get kicked out and they will
just process him into a single men's
Hotel
so it's you break the law it's not a war
we're going to report you to the proper
parties is let's give you a second or a
third hotel room and you're you still
stay in the city yeah it doesn't seem
like they're facing the same
consequences As Americans sounds like a
protected class Carlos you are a very
brave whistleblower and I think the
American people are very grateful for
you for letting us know where our tax
dollars are going thank you
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis